الان في الاراضي الفلسطينيه المحتله حيث
قتلت قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي الفلسطينيا
خلال مواجهات في نابلس في الضفه الغربيه
المحتله في حين اعلنت وزاره الصحه
الفلسطينيه اصابه خمسه وعشرين شخصا على
الاقل بينهم اربعه في حاله حرجه خلال
اقتحام وحدات خاصه من قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي مدينه نابلس وقال شهود عيان
الى قوات خاصه اسرائيليه توغلت داخل نابلس
وحاصرت احد المنازل بذريعه اعتقال مطلوبين
حيث اندلعت الشبكات مع مقاومين فلسطينيين
وسمع دوي انفجارات في المنطقه كما منع
الاحتلال طواقم الاسعاف من الوصول الى وسط
المدينه
هذه الصور المباشره الان من نابلس حيث
طبعا يبدو التوتر الان هو سيد الموقف
وتجمع شبان فلسطيني يرشقون ربما قوات
الاحتلال التي اقتحمت المدينه بالحجاره
وفي عمليه
ادت الى مقتل او استشهاد فلسطيني واصابه
خمسه وعشرين اخرين لحد الان في حسب وزاره
الصحه الفلسطينيه نعود مره اخرى للتذكير
بتفاصيل ما يجري انا في نابلس والاجواء
السائده هناك مع مدير مكتبه جزيره وليد
العمري اليك وليد
نعم الشهيد سقطا في مواجهات خارج المنطقه
التي او المبنى الذي تستهدفه قوات
الاحتلال المبنى ما يزال محاصر وهو في
منطقه السوق الشرقي من البلده القديمه
قوات الاحتلال عندما دخلت قصفته باربع
قذائف من قذائف مضاده حسب المعلومات كما
ان هناك تحليق لطائرات اباتشي ومسيرات في
المنطقه بالاضافه
للعائل من القوات التي تم تعزيزها خلال
الفتره الثانيه
والمعلومات تضيف ايضا بان هناك شهيد ثاني
في نابلس في هذه اللحظات اي ان هناك
شهيدان والشهيدان سقطا في المواجهات
الدائره خارج منطقه حي السوق الشرقي
المحاصر من قبل قوات الاحتلال
مستهدف فيه مبنى فيه مقاتلين فلسطينيين من
عرين الاسود
وحسب المعلومات ايضا فان قوات الاحتلال
تستهدف حتى الطواقم الاسعاف الطبيه
والصحفيين هناك صحفي اصيب وحسب الهلال فان
القوات الاحتلال تعرقل حتى محاولتهم اسعاف
المصابين والذين زاد عددهم حتى اللحظه على
25 جريحا بينهم مصابين اصاباتهم توصف
بانها من الخطيره والحرجه الرئاسه
الفلسطينيه على لسان الناطق باسمها نبيل
ابو ردينه اصدرت ادانا لمواصفات اقتحام
قوات الاحتلال مدينه نابلس وتطالب بوقف
الاعتداءات المستمره ضد الفلسطينيين بشكل
فوري هذا بيان عاجل صدر هذه اللحظه
التطورات الميدانيه في نابلس كما قلت هي
في منطقه السوق الشرقي لكنها تستهدف
البلده القديمه بالكامل هناك مواجهات مع
محتجين فلسطينيين في ارجاء المدينه وهناك
حصار للمبنى ولمناطق واسعه قوات الاحتلال
في الساعه الاخيره عادت ودفعت بتعزيزات
اضافيه القوه الاسرائيليه التي توغلت في
مدينه نابلس هي قوه مشكله من الجيش من
احدى وحدات الجيش وكذلك من وحده خاصه من
الشرطه تعرف باليمن وهناك ايضا وحده خاصه
من حرس الحدود وقد سبقهم الى داخل
القديمه قوه تعرف بالمستعربين وهي
كوماندوز يتخفى بالزي المدني عاده يتسلل
ويقوم
بتامين دخول القوات العسكريه في وقت لاحق
الجيش الاسرائيلي يقول بانه دخل لان لديه
معلومات عن مطلوبين اثنين في داخل هذا
المبنى وهو دخل يستهدفها لاعتقالهما لكن
المواجهات كما قلت اندلعت والاشتباكات
متواصله مع قوات الاحتلال هناك حتى الساعه
وفق وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه شهيدان وهناك
ايضا اكثر من 25 جريحا بينهم عدد جراحاتهم
توصف بانها حرجه لانه النيران اصابات
بعضهم في الراس والموقف يواصلوا تفجره
وتفجره في مدينه نابلس